home alone finally I've wanted to talk
about this movie forever on my channel I
grew up with this film this was my film
when I was a kid I must have replayed
this VHS tape I don't even know how many
times all the time was always on I
memorized the commercials that took
place before home alone started and
sometimes the song from this Pepsi
commercial still comes into my head I
have to show you the full shirt oh it's
beautiful and so ugly oh I love it
every single winter home alone is a must
home Alone's been a staple of my entire
life I adore this film let's talk about
it this movie was the highest-grossing
film of 1990 I was 2 years old when it
came out I obviously did not see this
film in theaters and it stars a little
innocent boy named Macaulay Culkin who
didn't stay innocent for very long and
little Kevin McCallister has such a huge
family you have his big brother buzz I
wouldn't let you sleep in my room if you
were growing on my ass and right now he
feels like everyone's kind of against
him his parents don't seem to like him
right now and then of course there's
Uncle Frank look what you did you little
jerk and of course as I'm sure basically
all of you know his parents go on this
vacation with all of their family and
accidentally leave him home alone and he
has to fend for himself when two
burglars played masterfully by Joe Pesci
and Daniel Stern decide to break into
his house for Christmas I made my family
disappear
what can I say that hasn't been said
already about home alone well when a
movie is this popular and so many people
have talked about it for various decades
already decades the best way that I can
provide an original experience for you
that's different from everyone else is
tell you my personal stories involving
this movie one story that I swear to you
is true I'm not making this up I right
hand to my heart this is true there's a
scene in this movie where Kevin
McCallister decides to take a sled and
go down the stairs of his home and he
launches out the front door he's having
the time of his life well when I was a
kid I wanted to do that too so I got in
the laundry basket the plastic laundry
basket and I went up to the top of the
steps and I sat in that laundry basket I
must have been four years old I don't
know four or five years old I got in
that laundry basket and I teetered on
the edge of those stairs and I just went
full-on all the way down the stairs in a
laundry basket I then for whatever
reason besides the fact that I did it
without getting caught decided I should
tell my parents what I just did because
I don't know it was just a good kid and
my mom laughed a lot and gratefully I
wasn't injured and she will tell that
story to you forever she will tell that
story to people until their ears fall
off and you bet as a kid I set up a lot
of micro machines I had micro machines
that had to go in front of doors and
people often were like Chris you're
gonna kill somebody you have a home
alone it's so good right yeah it's funny
Chris but you're gonna murder someone
yeah this movie has always had a
profound impact on me because it speaks
to the kid and all of us at the time
every kid has that moment where he
thinks the family's out to get him every
kid hates their parents for a few days
at some point or their entire lives who
knows but there's always that moment
when you're a kid where you're like
everyone hates me I hate my family I
want to be alone I want to live alone
when I grew up and get married I'm
living alone do you hear me I'm live
hello I gotta say this is a really well
directed movie it's not just a fun
childhood film as an adult I have
rewatched this every single year and I
find things each year that I appreciate
more about it Chris Columbus directed
this movie who later went on to direct
the first to Harry Potter films and he
has a great sense to him visually and
he's really good at setting up jokes
because the humor in this movie is on
point and it's not just the slapstick
humor of the booby-trap sequence which
we'll talk about it's actually the
editing this is a really well edited
movie he knows exactly when to put a
pause when not to put a pause when to
speed up the humor it's really well-made
I'm gonna get analytical about home
alone I don't care screw it there's a
scene that has perfect editing and
perfect comic timing it's such a small
moment here's the scene let's wait and
see who it is we worked his neighborhood
to supposing a cops finger was for a job
and they start asking us questions about
a murder in the area won't it be nice to
have a face to go with their questions
that's a good idea
which it's a good idea nowadays they
would have cut out that pause before
Daniel Stern says that's a good idea but
seeing him sitting there pondering about
it for a second just sells his
characters truth stupidity and it's
genius
editing the entire film has really good
editing like that and Macaulay Culkin
genuinely is perfect in this movie it's
one of the best child performances ever
he's amazing in this film he gave
everything that this film needed he was
the kid hero of the 90s he really was he
was that kid that every single kid was
like yes I want to be him I want to be
home alone I want to have all this fun I
want to set up booby traps I want to
steal my brother's BB gun buzz I'm going
through all your private stuff you
better come out and pound me no clothes
on anybody sickening no I gotta talk
more about the Wet Bandits Joe Pesci and
Daniel Stern as a kid I always thought
Joe Pesci was just Harry I had never
seen Goodfellas as a five-year-old
obviously but as an adult after I saw
Raging Bull and Goodfellas and Casino
and then I went back and watched home
alone I was like oh my god this was a
really big departure for Joe Pesci
shut it Marv and Daniel Stern as Marv
perfect
casting you can't even imagine him
played by someone else nowadays it's
impossible to even comprehend someone
other than Daniel Stern being with Joe
Pesci in this movie if you were to look
at a photo of these two in the year 1989
or whenever they started making this
movie you'd probably be like I don't
know about that their chemistry is
perfect we'll come back around 9 o'clock
that way it stopped then yeah kids are
scared of the dark you're free the dark
too Marv you know you are and how can I
not talk about the scene the aftershave
scene ba ba dum dum dum but uh but
doctor don't go to dinner uh dreaming of
a white Christmas just like the ones we
used to know dough dough dough dough
dough dough the film also has a Great
backstory with old man Marley this older
guy who walks up and down the streets
every night salting the sidewalks you
see that garbage can full of salt that's
where he keeps his victims the salt
turns the bodies into mummies it's such
a great bait and switch because even
John Williams score which by the way of
course is just it's it's perfect there's
nothing wrong with it's amazing even his
score sets up this guy to be this really
evil person every time it pans to him
don don don don
but then you get that beautiful
heartfelt scene in the church where
Kevin runs into him by accident and at
first he's really scared but this guy's
like you know what kid we need to talk
and he tells his backstory about how he
can't see his granddaughter anymore
because he had this really silly
argument with a son which provides that
hook which in the final moments of this
movie virtually every time I watch it I
cry a lot of it has to do with John
Williams music but it is a film that has
that hook in there as well of drama
especially involving Kevin when he
begins to realize that he truly does
love his family and wishes they were
here so not only is this a very funny
well directed movie with great
performances it's also a film that kids
can take away something special from in
the message category and then messages
hey you don't want your family around
well try not having them around for a
while you might want them back soon I
got to talk about angels with filthy
souls the best fake movie inside a real
movie ever I tell you what I'm gonna
give you snakes I'm gonna give you to
the count of 10 to get your ugly yellow
no-good four-flushing caucus out my door
1 to 10
Merry Christmas you filthy animal
there's such a great set up because you
see that tape early in the film and
Kevin's scared by it then he decides to
use it against people in the movie he
uses it against the little Nero's pizza
delivery guy and a great scene and he
uses it against Marv so the kid is smart
he uses his head adults can enjoy
watching this kid figure things out you
don't have to be a kid to be like yeah
this movie's entertaining I like movies
I'm a little boy as you get older you're
like that kid's clever I like that kid
and no scene in this film shows his
cleverness better than the supermarket
scene where's your mom
she's in the car where's your dad he's
at work what about your brothers and
your sisters I'm an only child where do
you live I can't tell you that why not
cuz you're a stranger it's like the
greatest comeback a kid has ever made in
a movie so let's talk about the booby
trap sequence as a kid this was always
the one I was most excited about I was
like oh we're not gonna hurt you
yeah it's Santa Claus and his elf be a
nice little fella and open the door this
sequence is hilarious everything about
it is just so gut-busting ly funny and
it's not just because the slapstick is
good as I said a lot of this has to do
with excellent editing and timing why
the hell you take your shoes off why the
hell you dress like a chicken you guys
give up are you thirsty for more you
bond me with one more can kid and I'll
snap up your cojones and boil it in
motor oil hello my house is being robbed
my address is 656 Lincoln Boulevard my
name is Murphy I watch home alone every
year it never gets old it never will I
adore this film it's one of my favorite
family movies it's one of my favorite
comedies it's easily my favorite winter
Christmas themed movie and I'm gonna
give home alone an A+
Bax thank you so much as always for
watching my review of home alone I hope
you guys are having a great winter break
if you're interested in a review of home
alone to my good buddy a longtime friend
John Flickinger aka the flick pick has
just posted his review for home alone to
lost in New York there's gonna be a link
for that in just a second here go over
to his review show him some love you
guys are the best thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get steppen
eyes